lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
repasar lo que hemos aprendido de
nuestras clases de química sobre la
oxidación muy bien sobre la oxidación y
también de digamos lo contrario a la
oxidación que es la reducción verdad
tenemos también la reducción y a partir
de esto ver que lo que hemos aprendido
en nuestras clases de química se
relaciona digamos desde el punto de
vista de un biólogo o de un químico
verdad cómo se utilizarían estas
palabras que ya hemos utilizado en
clases de química y espero que de hecho
veamos que en realidad es la misma cosa
verdad así que en realidad va a ser más
bien una especie de repaso verdad y si y
si viste los vídeos de química verdad la
lista de vídeos de química podríamos
pensar a la oxidación como no sé
podríamos simplemente simplificarlo
diciendo que es pero verdad pero
podríamos digamos leerlo así como que la
pérdida y voy a poner pérdida entre
comillas verdad la pérdida
electrones de electrones es oxidación
muy bien entonces la pérdida de
electrones es oxidación y en realidad
pongo estas comillas verdad porque no
necesariamente está ocurriendo que
estemos perdiendo electrones verdad pero
bueno también hemos hablado de la
reducción la reducción lo podríamos
escribir como como here verdad here
here y significaría que la ganancia
verdad y otra vez estamos utilizando
comillas porque no es no es tal cual
necesariamente que sea una ganancia de
verdad
la ganancia de electrones electrones es
reducción
ganancia de electrones es reducción
ahora porque hemos puesto estas comillas
bueno en realidad no es que estemos
necesariamente ganando o perdiendo
electrones lo que pasa es que en algún
átomo o alguna parte de la molécula está
acaparando los electrones y la razón por
la cual se le llama reducción verdad es
porque si estamos ganando electrones
digamos en nuestra nuestra carga se va a
reducir verdad y la razón por la cual le
llamamos oxidación a este lado es porque
tendemos a perder electrones hacia el
oxígeno y eso es digo no necesariamente
tiene que ser con el oxígeno verdad
podría ser cualquier otro átomo que
acapare electrones verdad y vamos a ver
un ejemplo muy bonito para que sea esto
mucho más concreto muy bien así que
digamos que tenemos
digamos hidrógeno molecular verdad vamos
a tomarnos dos moles de hidrógeno
molecular y digamos este está en un
estado gaseoso y digamos puedo hacer una
combustión con
oxígeno molecular entonces vamos a
agregar oxígeno molecular esto está en
estado gaseoso vamos a hacer una
combustión y lo que ocurre verdad es que
de hecho esto va a producir una gran
explosión cierto como lo que ocurrió en
hindenburg verdad simplemente llenaron
como un globo digamos con mucho
hidrógeno y con una pequeña chispa
verdad pues al exponerse vamos a tener
una gran explosión verdad pero en este
proceso por cada mol digamos de oxígeno
molecular si tenemos dos moles de
hidrógeno molecular vamos a producir dos
moles de agua verdad h2o muy bien más
bueno vamos a tener que producir también
muchísimo calor verdad y lo voy a poner
justamente en mayúsculas por este hecho
y entonces literalmente esta reacción va
a ser una explosión verdad entonces
ahora lo que quiero ver es exactamente
determinar qué es lo que se está
oxidando y qué es lo que se está
reduciendo así que en esta situación
tenemos
el hidrógeno y cómo se vería en este
caso el hidrógeno se vería justamente
así verdad tenemos un enlace entre dos
hidrógenos están cada uno compartiendo
un electrón con el otro así que digamos
que ambos pueden pretender que su
orbital 1 s está completamente lleno
verdad así que en realidad no están
perdiendo electrones con respecto al
otro no están digamos acaparando los
electrones del otro hidrógeno así que
podríamos pensar que tienen un estado de
oxidación neutro verdad simplemente no
han ganado ni perdido electrones solo lo
comparten y lo mismo es cierto para este
oxígeno molecular verdad aquí tenemos un
doble enlace entre los dos átomos de
oxígeno verdad simplemente son dos
oxígenos no hay ninguna razón por la
cual uno podría ganar o perder
electrones con respecto al otro verdad
sí así que si nos vamos del otro lado de
la ecuación verdad ocurren cosas
bastante interesantes que tenemos por
ejemplo que el oxígeno el oxígeno está
unido
estado digamos a estos dos átomos de
hidrógeno y la forma en la que pensamos
esto es que el oxígeno está acaparando
cada uno de los electrones de estos dos
hidrógenos así que el hidrógeno tiene un
electrón en su capa de valencia verdad y
el trato digamos cuando hacemos un
enlace covalente es es que nosotros
tenemos un electrón y me das un electrón
a cambio y entonces en realidad estamos
completando un par verdad pero nosotros
sabemos o al menos podemos repasar que
el oxígeno es mucho más electro negativo
que el hidrógeno verdad y entonces aquí
tenemos lo que teníamos anteriormente de
nuestro vídeo de la respiración celular
verdad tenemos una molécula de glucosa y
ahorita vamos a ignorarlo por un rato
simplemente vamos a conectarlo todo esto
después en un vídeo posterior verdad
pero si nos fijamos en nuestra tabla
periódica si nos estamos fijando en
nuestra tabla periódica y recordamos
todo lo que hemos visto en la lista de
vídeos de química verdad la electro
negatividad aumenta
a medida que nos vamos moviendo hacia la
esquina superior derecha verdad estos
elementos de aquí digamos son los más
electro negativos muy bien estos estos
elementos de aquí lo voy a marcar un
poquito mejor estos que tenemos aquí son
los más electro negativos mientras que
los que se encuentran de este lado son
los menos electro negativos verdad así
que todo lo que significa la electro
negatividad es que nos gusta acaparar
electrones y vamos a notar eso entonces
la electro negatividad electro
negatividad o si un átomo es electro
negativo es porque le gusta acaparar
electrones acapara electrones
acapara electrones en nuestro caso
aunque el oxígeno y el hidrógeno verdad
estén en un enlace covalente verdad para
formar el agua están compartiendo
electrones en realidad el oxígeno es
mucho más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno verdad entonces le va a gustar
digamos a acaparar esos electrones y de
hecho va a tomar por ejemplo si nosotros
tomamos otros elementos de este lado
derecho verdad y si los unimos con
algunos tipos que se encuentran del lado
izquierdo esto es de la derecha verdad
como son más electro negativos que los
de la izquierda en realidad van a robar
completamente el electrón verdad no sólo
lo van a acaparar digamos por el por un
mayor periodo de tiempo sino si lo van a
tomar completamente pero bueno cuando
hablamos de la electro negatividad
simplemente significa que los electrones
verdad tenderán a pasar alrededor de
cierto átomo verdad así que cuando nos
fijamos en el enlace entre el hidrógeno
y el oxígeno verdad vimos en la tabla
periódica que el oxígeno es muy
más electro negativo y por lo tanto los
electrones tenderán a pasar más tiempo
cerca del oxígeno verdad de hecho
aprendimos que se crea una carga parcial
negativa en este lado de la molécula de
agua verdad crea y por otro lado crea
cargas parciales positivas de este otro
lado de la molécula en donde se
encuentran los hidrógenos y de vez en
cuando entonces los electrones estarán
pasando alrededor de los hidrógenos
cuando hablamos de digamos la oxidación
y la reducción verdad en realidad no es
que estemos pensando en cargas parciales
verdad sí sí digamos un uno de estos se
está acaparando los electrones digamos
mucho más tiempo para fines de estudiar
los estados de oxidación vamos a suponer
que en realidad tomo los electrones así
que para un estado de oxidación vamos a
suponer que el oxígeno en el agua tiene
los electrones verdad y le vamos a dar
un estado de óxidos de oxidación
- 2 vamos a escribirlo aquí el oxígeno
tiene un estado de oxidación de 2 - de
hecho esta es la convención verdad vamos
a describir la carga ya sea positiva o
negativa después de el número verdad de
estados de oxidación así que esto es
para que no te confundas cuando hablamos
de las cargas reales que tiene el átomo
verdad así que este es uno dos menos
verdad porque desde el punto de vista de
la oxidación en realidad está tomando
los electrones verdad y entonces está
ganando esos dos electrones uno por cada
uno de estos hidrógenos de ahí es que
poníamos eso de ganar o perder
electrones entre comillas no es que como
tal los esté ganando o perdiendo
simplemente los está acaparando y en
general cuando el oxígeno se está
uniendo digamos con otro átomo que no es
oxígeno verdad u otro elemento que no es
oxígeno tenderá a tener un estado de
oxidación de 2 - ahora vamos a escribir
esto con comillas verdad en realidad
pensamos que
pensamos que ganó dos electrones dos
electrones otra vez de donde ganó esos
electrones pues de los electrones del de
cada uno de estos hidrógenos cierto ok
entonces si y si el oxígeno ganó los
electrones de estos hidrógenos por otro
lado cada uno de estos tipos perdió un
electrón verdad así que el estado de
oxidación de cada uno de ellos va a ser
uno más el estado de oxidación de cada
uno va a ser uno más así que en general
decimos que al hacer una combustión del
hidrógeno con el oxígeno verdad los
hidrógenos digamos antes estos dos
hidrógenos tenían un estado de oxidación
neutro verdad un estado de oxidación
cero y ahora tienen un estado de
oxidación uno más
simplemente porque perdieron los
electrones verdad han perdido los
electrones y por eso es que tienen este
nuevo estado de oxidación al ser digamos
al unirse con el oxígeno así que
podríamos concluir de aquí
y el hidrógeno se ha oxidado así que
vamos a escribirlo de aquí podemos
concluir que el hidrógeno
el hidrógeno se ha oxidado se ha oxidado
eso es cuando hablamos del hidrógeno
verdad y ahora porque se ha oxidado
bueno eso es porque antes era capaz de
digamos compartir sus electrones de
forma adecuada pero al unirse con el
oxígeno verdad que está acaparando los
electrones entonces el hidrógeno está
perdiendo esos electrones hacia el
oxígeno verdad así que se está oxidando
similarmente si el hidrógeno se ha
oxidado podemos concluir entonces que el
oxígeno el oxígeno se ha reducido
reducido
se ha reducido y porque se ha reducido
bueno justamente cuando teníamos esta
molécula de oxígeno verdad gaseoso en
realidad no estaba ni perdiendo ni
ganando electrones pero cuando se ha
unido con otro elemento con una electro
negatividad más baja verdad
inmediatamente empieza a acaparar los
electrones y entonces pensamos que está
ganando esos electrones así que en
realidad podemos pensar que esa carga
hipotética se está reduciendo por dos
verdad y si quisiera de hecho digamos
considerar todos los electrones verdad
porque cuando estamos hablando de
pérdida y ganancia de electrones
podríamos escribir dos semi reacciones
verdad y esto es más que nada un pequeño
repaso de las clases de química verdad
pero nunca nunca le hace daño a nadie
digamos verlo de nuevo verdad así que
vamos a recordar todo esto en la lista
de vídeos de biología de para que
digamos puedas refrescar su memoria con
todo este material así que vamos a
escribir dos semi reacciones podríamos
pensar que si empezamos con
dos moles de hidrógeno molecular
teníamos dos moles de hidrógeno
molecular y si no tenía digamos algún
estado de oxidación o más bien su estado
de oxidación eran neutro verdad entonces
podríamos poner un cero aquí arriba
verdad si quisiéramos pero bueno del
otro lado que es lo que vamos a obtener
vamos a obtener dos moles de hidrógeno
verdad de h2 pero en este caso tienen un
estado de oxidación distinto en este
caso tienen un estado de oxidación uno
más o bien otra forma de pensarlo desde
la siguiente forma que tenemos en
realidad cuatro hidrógenos aquí verdad
con un estado de oxidación uno más de
hecho así es como lo voy a poner
voy a poner que tenemos cuatro
hidrógenos aquí tendríamos cuatro
hidrógenos cada uno de ellos tiene un
estado de oxidación uno más
y cada uno de esos hidrógenos ha perdido
un electrón así que estamos perdiendo en
total 4 electrones verdad entonces está
semi reacción que tenemos aquí nos está
diciendo que el hidrógeno se oxida el
hidrógeno se óxido bien el hidrógeno se
óxido y esa es la semi reacción para el
hidrógeno y ha perdido 4 electrones
ahora si quisiéramos escribir la otra
semi reacción verdad es decir estaríamos
pensando en el oxígeno nosotros teníamos
oxígeno molecular y ahora en este caso
está ganando 4 electrones verdad son los
4 electrones que perdió el hidrógeno
verdad entonces qué es lo que nos va a
dar esto esto nos va a dar 2 oxígeno es
verdad pero estos oxígenos ahora tienen
un estado de oxidación distinto que es 2
- entonces lo que aquí nos está diciendo
es que el oxígeno se redujo
oxígeno
redujo muy bien hasta aquí todo fue muy
bueno fue un repaso pequeño de lo que
hemos aprendido en clases de química y
ahora vamos a hacer un poquito las cosas
más confusas verdad porque voy ahora
introducirte a cómo ve un biólogo la
oxidación y la reducción así que digo no
siempre es el caso a veces los biólogos
también utilizan la definición que hemos
aprendido en las clases de química
verdad pero digamos un biólogo o en
algunos textos de libros de textos de
biología digamos van a van a decir que
la oxidación es la pérdida de átomos de
hidrógeno verdad y esto de hecho solía
confundirme mucho así que vamos a
escribirlo vamos a escribir esa
definición que usan a veces los biólogos
y es que la oxidación la oxidación es
pérdida es pérdida de átomos de
hidrógeno
átomos átomos de hidrógeno muy bien y
por el contrario entonces la reducción
la reducción
la reducción es ganancia en este caso
sería ganancia no de electrones sino en
este caso sería ganancia de átomos
átomos de hidrógeno muy bien y en unos
momentos te voy a decir por qué estas
definiciones son completamente
compatibles y en realidad esto es
digamos porque en el en el mundo
biológico verdad vamos a poner que todo
esto sería en el mundo biológico esto
sería en el mundo biológico en el mundo
biológico tenemos que el hidrógeno
digamos puede unirse a digamos otro tipo
de átomos por ejemplo se puede unir con
el carbono se puede unir con el oxígeno
se puede unir con el nitrógeno y se
puede unir con el fósforo verdad entre
otros y si nos fijamos en la tabla
periódica vamos a regresar a la tabla
periódica aquí tenemos otra vez el
carbono el nitrógeno el oxígeno verdad y
también tenemos el fósforo entonces el
hidrógeno se puede unir con
todos estos y si vemos en realidad el
estos estos cuatro elementos son mucho
más electro negativos que el hidrógeno
así que si digamos tuviéramos un carbono
verdad que éste aunque estuviera unido
con un hidrógeno entonces en este caso
el carbono está acaparando el electrón
verdad luego si ese hidrógeno digamos se
transfiere digamos a un oxígeno verdad
junto con el electrón entonces el
carbono estaría perdiendo el hidrógeno
verdad el átomo de hidrógeno pero en
realidad también estaría perdiendo el
electrón que estaba acaparando antes
verdad entonces ahora el oxígeno es
quien está acaparando el electrón así
que estás en realidad son definiciones
consistentes y la razón
digamos por la cual quería mostrarte
este ejemplo que digamos hicimos aquí
abajo
es porque la definición biológica de
oxidación y reducción no aplica aquí
digo si podríamos decir bueno el oxígeno
definitivamente está ganando hidro
átomos de hidrógeno verdad en esta
reacción definitivamente se está
reduciendo desde ese punto de vista pero
desde el punto de vista biológico verdad
no podríamos decir que el hidrógeno está
perdiendo hidrógenos aquí verdad en esta
situación el hidrógeno solo está
perdiendo electrones verdad no es como
que se esté perdiendo a sí mismo digo
podríamos pensar que si se está
perdiendo a sí mismo verdad porque está
digamos siendo tomado por el oxígeno
pero en resumidas cuentas desde la
definición biológica tenemos la misma
idea verdad cuando el hidrógeno está
unido con otras cosas verdad en
compuestos biológicos tiende a ceder
electrones verdad así que si un carbono
pierde un hidrógeno en realidad está
digamos por ejemplo cediendo lo a un
oxígeno verdad entonces el carbono va a
perder el electrón del hidrógeno que
estaba acaparando verdad y ahora el
oxígeno lo está acá
así que el carbono se estaría oxidando
verdad y el oxígeno y el oxígeno estaría
siendo reducido espero que esto no te
haya confundido mucho en el próximo
vídeo voy a mostrarte un par de ejemplos
más verdad y toda la razón por la cual
estoy tratando de decir esto es porque
quiero aplicarlo a la respiración
celular verdad así que esto es para que
no nos confundamos cuando las personas
nos digan que el nada verdad se está
reduciendo cuando digamos toma un
hidrógeno o que se está oxidando cuando
pierde un hidrógeno verdad y así
sucesivamente sólo quería que vieras que
estás dos definiciones que hemos
aprendido en las clases de química y con
la que ahora estamos dando desde el
punto de vista biológico son
completamente compatibles